[Musique]
bonjour à tous je m'appelle Mélissa
spilman et si je suis ici devant vous
aujourd'hui c'est pour vous partager mon
rêve ou plutôt comment j'ai compris que
mon rêve c'était le mien je suis né à
l'île de la Réunion et j'ai grandi à
Sainte-Rose c'est une petite ville
connectée à la nature et grandir dans
cette environnement ça m'a vraiment
permis d'aimer la nature et de mieux
connaître qui j'étais vraiment
avec le temps j'ai réalisé que j'avais
beaucoup de chance de pouvoir vivre à
Sainte-Rose c'est une ville où
l'agriculture et le tourisme domine et
mes parents ils avaient un restaurant
une auberge et chambre d'hôtes et un
terrain agricole il transformait dans le
restaurant Les produits de leur
exploitation et grandir dans cet
environnement ça m'a permis de
rencontrer différentes cultures déjà à
la Réunion il y a vraiment une vraie
mixité culturelle et en plus et ben moi
je pouvais côtoyer des gens du monde
entier et découvrir différentes façons
de penser
quand j'avais 8 ans je me souviens que
j'étais assise sur la terrasse du
restaurant et à ce moment là il s'est
passé quelque chose chez moi j'ai eu
beaucoup de gratitude parce que j'étais
là assise sur sur la terrasse du
restaurant comme d'habitude et je
prenais mon petit déjeuner c'était une
assiette remplie de fruits tropicaux
délicieux et en face de moi il y avait
un palmier et ce palmier pour une fois
il était fleuri et il y avait une
multitude d'abeilles qui elles aussi
venez prendre leur petit déjeuner en
même temps que moi alors que il y avait
la mer et le et le soleil qui était qui
était en train de se lever en même temps
que nous et j'ai réalisé que j'avais
beaucoup de chance parce que Ben j'étais
là assise tranquillement à prendre mon
petit déjeuner et que j'avais juste à
traverser la route pour aller prendre le
bus et aller à l'école du coup j'ai 8
ans et je réalise que j'ai beaucoup de
sens et que ce que je veux faire dans la
vie c'est redonner autant que j'ai reçu
du coup plus tard en grandissant cette
conviction elle est restée fortement
ancrée en moi et j'ai décidé de saisir
ma chance et d'apprendre pleinement
cette quête de l'apprentissage elle m'a
amenée à découvrir plein de choses déjà
j'ai réalisé qu'on n'était pas tous
égaux face à l'apprentissage on n'avait
pas tous les mêmes chances déjà rien que
sur notre île on pouvait on n'avait pas
tous ce même accès parce que Ben plus
tard j'ai déménagé à Saint-Gilles enfin
mes parents ont déménagé à Saint-Gilles
et du coup j'ai découvert qu'il y avait
deux mondes sur notre île il y avait
l'Est et l'Ouest et c'est pas du tout la
même chose dans l'Est c'est plutôt rural
l'Ouest c'est un peu plus urbanisé et en
fait avoir la chance d'habiter dans dans
l'Ouest ça nous a permis avec ma sœur de
découvrir plein de choses et surtout de
nouveaux sports donc à ce moment là on a
découvert l'accès à la mer on a
découvert le sport qui était le surf et
le bodyboard donc c'est une passion que
notre père il nous a transmis et en fait
avoir la chance de pouvoir faire ce
genre de sport ou des sports plus
créatif comme la danse ou faire de la
peinture chose qu'on n'avait pas
forcément accès à Sainte-Rose et ben ça
nous a vraiment construit et ça nous a
permis d'avoir plus confiance en nous
aujourd'hui je suis très fière d'être
réunionnaise et de ne pas avoir peur de
la mer d'ailleurs je sais que grâce aux
surf et ben j'ai beaucoup plus confiance
en moi et je me sens capable de relever
beaucoup de défis parce que quand
j'arrive à prendre une grosse vague et
bah je me dis que je peux réussir tout
ce que je veux dans ma vie
ensuite plus grande j'ai continué cette
quête de l'apprentissage et j'ai
découvert des choses qui m'ont un peu
révolté donc je me suis sentie vachement
révolté parce que tout simplement on
n'avait pas le même accès à
l'apprentissage mais je savais que ça
allait plus loin que ça en fait j'ai
découvert que la richesse dans notre
monde elle est illimitée et ça va
révolté de me rendre compte qu'on
essayait de toujours de nous mettre dans
des cases et que ces cases ne servaient
que à nous faire croire que la richesse
n'était réservée qu'à une élite et à ce
moment-là ma colère elle m'a amené à
vouloir combattre le mal par le mal et
donc j'ai décidé que j'allais faire des
millions pour changer le monde et des
renverser la société
alors du coup ça c'est pas passé comme
ça mais du coup j'ai découvert ce qu'on
appelle le marketing de réseau à
l'époque on nous vendait ça comme une
solution miraculeuse pour faire de
l'argent très rapidement j'ai découvert
que c'était plus une illusion de gloire
et d'argent mais que c'était pas du tout
fait pour moi mais j'ai beaucoup appris
avec cette expérience et j'ai pu faire
beaucoup de formations et de séminaire
c'est là que j'ai découvert le
développement personnel et surtout les
lois de l'univers
à ce moment là
et ben je me souviens que j'avais
investi mes dernières économies dans une
formation qui se déroulaient à en
Roumanie à Bucarest et du coup ben je
m'étais rendu en Roumanie et j'étais
vraiment déterminé à découvrir comment
on fait de l'argent et donc j'attendais
vraiment un vrai déclic et je me
souviens pas de toutes les conférenciers
qu'on a eu ce jour-là mais je me
souviens d'un homme qui était sur scène
et qui m'a beaucoup impacté en fait il
avait tout ce que je voulais il avait la
richesse il avait réussi à mettre sa
famille à l'abri et il était là devant
nous à nous partager son histoire pour
nous impacter et du coup il nous a fait
faire de la visualisation créatrice à ce
moment là j'ai découvert ce que c'était
et ça m'a transformé donc il nous a fait
nous lever tous ensemble on était plus
de 5000 personnes dans la salle et au
milieu de cette énergie folle et ben moi
je me suis mise à fond et du coup il
nous a fait visualiser et il nous a dit
que si on arrivait à visualiser notre
pourquoi normalement on finirait par en
pleurer et que ce pourquoi il nous
permettrait de tout réaliser et donc moi
j'ai vu ma famille j'ai vu ma famille
heureuse et en harmonie et en train de
voyager et il faut savoir qu'à ce moment
là ma famille n'était plus vraiment une
famille parce que mes parents avaient
beaucoup de problèmes d'argent et qu'il
se disputait beaucoup et donc moi
j'étais parti à 13000 km pour me guérir
d'une colère qui aujourd'hui je réalise
était vite de sens
et en fait à ce moment là et ben je me
suis dit que c'était ça mon rêve mais
j'ai eu une deuxième vision celle de moi
en train de mener une conférence et
impacter des gens et on peut dire que ce
rêve là il se réalise un petit peu
aujourd'hui parce que je suis là devant
vous mais sur le coup quand je suis
rentré à Toulouse et ben je me suis pas
vraiment souvenu de ce rêve là et je me
suis plus souvenu de ma famille donc
j'avais je m'étais dit que ce que je
voulais c'était faire de l'argent pour
sauver ma famille et aussi sauver le
monde
plus tard j'ai compris que le marketing
de réseau du coup c'était pas fait pour
moi et j'ai décidé de me lancer dans
l'entrepreneuriat parce que finalement
j'avais découvert plein de choses et que
je me sentais totalement capable de
d'ouvrir mon entreprise sauf que pareil
ça c'est pas passé comme je m'y
attendais et
je voulais vraiment changer les choses
donc je me suis dit que si je voulais
réussir dans l'entrepreneuriat il
fallait que je rentre à la Réunion il
fallait que je rentre à la Réunion pour
être libre de mon temps et ne plus être
dans cette case de salarié qui échangent
beaucoup de temps qu'on peu d'argent
donc je suis rentrée chez moi et le
retour a été assez brutal tout d'abord
parce que ben je me suis retrouvé
confronté à ma famille qui est elle
avait une réalité totalement différente
de la mienne qui était plus terre à
terre plus désagriculteurs et moi
j'étais dans mon monde un peu dans cette
idée de visualisation créatrice et on va
dire qu'il me trouvait un peu bisounours
du coup ben je me sentais pas du tout à
ma place et j'avais vraiment du mal à
savoir comment j'allais faire pour
réaliser mon rêve
finalement
rentrer à Sainte-Rose ça m'a vraiment
sauvé parce que je me suis retrouvé plus
connectée plus connecté à une vie ben du
coup plus naturelle à connecter à une
vie qui vit au rythme du soleil et où
ben j'ai redécouvert l'agriculture et je
me suis rendu compte que l'agriculture
c'était vraiment un défi d'avenir
pourquoi parce que au final je pense que
elle est là notre abondance elle est
dans la nature et du coup cet abondance
qui nous était cachée et ben moi je la
redécouvrais dans ma vie de tous les
jours et j'ai aussi compris que si je
voulais aller mieux avec ma famille il a
les falloir que j'utilise tout ce que
j'avais appris jusqu'à maintenant et que
je l'avais appris que dans le but de me
changer moi de me changer de l'intérieur
vous savez en créole on a une expression
qui dit la peau de camarade que les pas
bon c'est où et en fait j'ai compris que
c'était pas les autres qui étaient pas
bon c'était pas ma famille qui me voyait
mal c'était moi et que je devais changer
de l'intérieur du coup j'ai recommencé à
me développer j'ai recommencé à investir
en moi mais cette fois-ci plus pour
gagner de l'argent mais plutôt pour mon
abondance et pour servir mon rêve parce
que du coup grâce à tout ça j'avais
découvert mon rêve et en faisant tout ça
et ben vous savez quoi je me suis à
nouveau rapproché de ma famille et il
s'est passé un truc merveilleux c'est
que j'ai redécouvert ma sœur ma sœur
c'est une fille extraordinaire et je
suis tellement heureuse de pouvoir
cheminer avec elle aujourd'hui parce que
c'est une personne qui est capable de
reprendre sa vie en main et qui a
surtout réussi à
mettre en place ses rêves et du coup
elle et moi et ben on a décidé que ce
qu'on voulait dans la vie et ben c'était
de voir une réunion autosuffisante une
réunion beaucoup plus harmonieuse et on
a réalisé que si on voulait le réaliser
et ben il fallait d'abord commencer par
nous par chez nous directement et par
notre famille
alors on a décidé d'entreprendre des
projets agro-environnementaux et je suis
tellement fière d'elle parce que
aujourd'hui elle lance son entreprise et
surtout et ben elle a décidé de se
lancer dans la transformation végétale
c'était un pas très difficile à prendre
parce que pour nous c'est un véritable
héritage familial comme je vous ai dit
mon père ma grand-mère et ma tante il y
a 30 ans ils ont décidé de s'installer à
Sainte-Rose et c'était pas un choix
facile pour eux parce qu'il venait de
perdre leur père et donc ils ont mis
tout leur héritage dans ce projet là et
plus tard ils ont été rejoints par ma
mère mais ils ont tous été portés par
cette envie de transmettre une certaine
forme d'Abondance à la Réunion et
l'importance que de l'entrepreneuriat et
aujourd'hui avec ma sœur et ben on
reprend ce flambeau et ce rêve au final
c'est pas vraiment le nôtre mais je
pense que c'est le moteur de qui je suis
aujourd'hui et surtout c'est lui qui me
permet de croire que tout est possible
et de surmonter tous les obstacles
si aujourd'hui je peux vous affirmer que
notre rêve il sera réalité c'est parce
que j'ai compris qu'il y avait trois
clés nécessaires à la réalisation à la
manifestation de tous les rêves et je
vais les partager avec vous aujourd'hui
donc la première clé je pense que c'est
d'avoir une vision nette et précise de
ce qu'on veut réaliser pour ça moi j'ai
entrepris de beaucoup visualiser du coup
et ça je l'ai fait grâce à notamment
l'écriture donc tous les jours
j'écrivais beaucoup et je me suis mise
dans dans la peau de la Mélissa gagnante
j'ai imaginé comment je me sentirai si
mon rêve était réalité et du coup j'ai
commencé à me demander qu'est-ce que ça
ferait de vivre dans une communauté
bienveillante et autosuffisante
qu'est-ce que ça ferait d'avoir accès à
des produits sains et surtout
respectueux de tous les êtres vivants de
la nature qu'est-ce que ça ferait de
vivre dans un monde où tout le monde
pourrait déployer son plein potentiel
dans l'amour et dans le respect et
qu'est-ce que ça ferait aussi de pouvoir
apprendre ses lois de l'abondance
qu'est-ce qu'on apprendrait si on devait
apprendre les lois de l'abondance
qu'est-ce qu'on ferait et du coup je me
suis imaginé en train de faire des
activités très en train de tresser des
fibres végétales locales en train de
découvrir de nouvelles activités
manuelles comme la poterie ou l'art et
j'ai commencé à faire ces activités et
le changement a commencé en moi ensuite
ça m'a amené à la deuxième clé et j'ai
découvert que c'était important d'être
dans le lâcher prise et dans
l'acceptation parce que parfois on
visualise mais on sait pas comment ça
peut arriver ni quand ça va arriver et
si on accepte pas et ben parfois on
n'est pas prêt à accueillir et du coup
j'ai appris à ne rien prendre
personnellement et ça ça m'a permis de
retrouver mes parents parce que Ben en
réalité souvent ils avaient des
réactions que je ne comprenais pas et
avec le temps j'ai compris que ce qui
leur manière de réagir elle ne
m'appartenait pas et surtout elle
n'était pas dirigée contre moi c'était
plus parce qu'ils avaient peur que je
vive les mêmes expériences que et que je
ressente les mêmes tristesses ou les
mêmes douleurs que et qui voulaient
juste me protéger en comprenant ça j'ai
pu à nouveau ben partager avec eux et
surtout ben j'ai pu découvrir que eux
aussi ils avaient le même rêve que moi
au fond
et ça ça m'a amené à la troisième clé la
troisième clé je pense c'est d'avoir une
fois inébranlable que ce soit une fois
en vous en votre projet ou bien en
quelque chose de plus grand qui nous
unit tous et ben je pense qu'il faut
avoir la foi moi j'ai choisi d'avoir la
foi et qu'elle soit inébranlable surtout
cette force qui nous unit tous et quand
j'ai décidé ça et ben j'ai commencé à
observer mon monde autour de moi du coup
tous les jours je faisais beaucoup de
gratitude pour Ben me rendre compte à
quel point on avait la chance de vivre
dans un monde aussi beau mais j'ai
surtout aussi beaucoup observer les gens
autour de moi et c'est là que j'ai
réalisé que je rencontrais des gens
extraordinaires qui avaient souvent ce
même rêve comme moi et qui avait souvent
cette même envie de changer les choses
et ça ça m'a permis d'augmenter ma foi
tous les jours ensuite il s'est passé
quelque chose d'extraordinaire c'est que
j'avais toujours rêvé d'avoir un mentor
et très récemment j'ai rencontré mon
mentor ou plutôt mon père me l'a
présenté parce que c'est aussi son
menteur à lui encore une fois rien ne
vient de moi mais du coup ce mentor il a
vraiment ce que je veux dans la vie
toutes les connaissances que je voulais
pour voir que mon rêve devienne réalité
il les a ça fait plus de 20 ans qu'il
les apprend donc j'ai 20 ans de vie au
final et ça bah j'ai trouvé ça vraiment
incroyable de pouvoir côtoyer des
personnes qui me permettent de grandir
et d'être la personne que je veux être
et ben ça va juste permis d'augmenter ma
foi et j'ai un dernier secret à vous
partager c'est que
j'ai utilisé un mantra et ce mantra il
m'a permis vraiment de devenir plus
discipliné grâce à lui tous les jours
j'arrive à mettre en place mes habitudes
parce que Ben tout simplement j'arrive à
contrôler moment mental et ses habitudes
elle me permettent de servir mon rêve
parce que ben elles augmentent ma vision
elles augmentent ma foi et elle me
permettent de lâcher prise alors je vais
partager avec vous ce mantra mais bien
sûr ben vous pouvez l'aimer ou pas mais
je tenais vraiment à le partager parce
qu'il a été le fondement de qui je suis
aujourd'hui
et pour finir et ben je vais vous
inviter à vous poser une question cette
question je pense qu'elle est très
importante je voudrais vous demander
comment est-ce que vous voulez impacter
dans votre vie parce que moi c'est la
question qui m'a permis de en arriver là
et de cheminer sur ce chemin qui est
l'acte de soi et je vais vous demander
de pas réfléchir à dans 10 ans ou dans
cinq ans mais plutôt maintenant quelle
action vous pouvez mettre en place dès
maintenant pour impacter votre vie et
celle autour de vous voilà merci de
m'avoir écouté et avec hichema
[Applaudissements]